on connaît le phénomène de la résistance
en médecine humaine et animale
les antibiotiques ne font plus effet
parce que des bactéries ont développé
une résistance à ces médicaments au
chant on observe ce phénomène aussi en
nombre croissant de mauvaises herbes
survivre aux herbicides ce qui
représente un véritable casse tête pour
les agriculteurs
[Musique]
montérégie ouest fait ou 2021 l'agronome
d'avis de girardville inspecte un champ
de soya avec l'agriculteur christian
bros le ps et les gros plans c'est eux
qui font le plus de green
[Musique]
wood qui comptera des plats comme ça
c'est quand même assez
cette plante qui dépasse la culture de
soya c'est de l'herbe à poux mais pas
n'importe laquelle de l'herbe à poux
résistantes aux herbicides un plan
matures peut produire jusqu'à 3000
graines qui vont se disséminer
facilement dans l'environnement une fois
qu'elle est long on est pris avec puis
le repos on récolte des machines se
promène d'un champ à l'autre on parle
des oiseaux on parle du verre il y a
quelques années des plantes qui semblait
avoir survécu aux épandages d'herbicides
attire l'attention du producteur quant à
eux tout est mort mais l'herbe à poux
est encore le jeu se pose des questions
sur comment ça se fait que finalement
sur fait une deuxième application c'est
comme de l'autre mais dessus c'est de
l'eau facile que ça marche plus les
herbicides pourtant puissants n'ont plus
aucun effet des analyses en laboratoire
confirme alors qu'il s'agit d'herbe à
poux résistante une plante qui pose
problème entre autres au moment de la
moisson
c'est plus difficile a récolté parce que
c'est encore voir souvent quand on
rigole des fois ça peut tacher aussi la
fin de la vidéo ci-dessus à
l'exportation l'alimentation humaine
mais à partir du moment qui est haché
peu déclassé être déclassé et donc vendu
moins cher et le cas de christian bros
est loin d'être unique
à quelques kilomètres de là david girard
ville prend des échantillons dans un
autre champ ici le soya est presque
complètement étouffés par la mauvaise
herbe c'est typique d'un début
d'infestation c'est à dire on a d'abord
un clan de plantes qui après ça ça ça
grandit et l'année passée on avait une
colonie d'herbe à poux qui était
beaucoup plus petit et puis cette année
comme on a eu une répétition de ces
traits gillot c'est là que c'était du
sérieux là n'est pas assez cette année
c'est du soyons encore les mêmes hobbies
signer puis donc le rond s'est agrandie
les premières mauvaises herbes
résistantes aux herbicides sont apparus
dans les années 50 au tout début de
l'utilisation de ces produits mais
depuis 30 ans les cas se multiplient
après les états unis et l'australie le
canada est le pays qui compte le plus
grand nombre de mauvaises herbes
résistantes au monde dans les prairies
seulement on estime que la résistance
coûte plus d'un demi milliard de dollars
aux agriculteurs chaque année jusqu'à
tout récemment le québec était
relativement épargnée je pense qu'au
québec on sous-estimé la résistance
beaucoup elle est beaucoup plus
éparpillé qu'on la cherche on la trouve
presque instantanément si mal hommes
c'est comme ça la résistance n'a
pourtant rien d'étonnant c'est un
exemple de sélection naturelle ya des
modifications qui fait que naturellement
il ya parmi les milliers de graines une
graine qui va avoir la faculté de
résister par exemple un pesticide
quand on utilise à répétition les mêmes
herbicides comme c'est souvent le cas
dans les monocultures de rares individus
auront le bagage génétique pour survivre
ces plantes sont les seuls qui
arriveront à produire des graines elles
transmettront ensuite leurs jeunes aux
générations futures
utilisez toujours les mêmes herbicides
crée donc une pression de sélection
année après année les spécimens
résistants sont de plus en plus nombreux
[Musique]
depuis les débuts de l'agriculture on se
servait d'outil mécanique pour se
débarrasser des indésirables mais en à
peine un demi siècle les sharks leur et
autres instruments aratoires ont été
remplacés par des herbicides aujourd'hui
beaucoup de fermes ne dépendre que de
ces traitements chimiques pour éliminer
les plantes qui poussent au mauvais
endroit mais pour combien de temps
nous sommes dans la région des
laurentides
dans une chaleur accablante on désherbe
à la main
notre priorité la première année il faut
empêcher la mauvaise herbe pour qu'elles
produisent des graines un diminuer le le
plus rapidement possible la banque de
semences
ce que l'équipe de l'agronome fairouz
dif arrache aujourd'hui c'est de
l'amarante tubercules et chaque plan est
soigneusement placé dans un sac de
plastique car on a ici affaire à une
championne de la survie c'est plus lent
ça peut donner beaucoup de grains
jusqu'à en moyenne de 300 mille grains
jusqu'à un million par plant famille des
graines minuscule qui peuvent survivre
pendant des années dans le sol avant de
germer la mare en tube a reculé c'est la
plus problématique dans notre région
d'ath
au québec l'amarante tuberculés a été
détecté pour la première fois en 2010
est à ce jour une quarantaine de foyers
d'infestation ont été découverts dans le
midwest américain où elle est indigène
cette plante est l'une des pires
mauvaises herbes et elles gagnent aussi
du terrain ailleurs au canada
en ontario des chercheurs ont démontré
qu'elle peut entraîner des baisses
moyennes de rendement dans le soya de
43% mais ces pertes peuvent atteindre
100 % quand l'amarante est très
compétitive
dans ce chan
on l'a découvert cette année on a fait
le premier passage d'arrachage date de
21 juillet à peine un mois plus tard les
plans qui n'avait pas été complètement
arraché ont poussé de trois centimètres
par jour ils sont déjà en fleurs et
produiront bientôt des graines une
plante profiteuse quand elle trouve la
chaleur l'espace entre les rangs saha
pouces pieds ça explose
ce qui la rend si redoutable c'est
qu'elle est capable de germer tout au
long de la saison mais surtout elle est
résistante non pas à un herbicide mais à
plusieurs dont le glyphosate le plus
utilisé au canada mieux connu sous le
nom commercial de rwanda le roundup
c'est le moins cher sur le marché puis
efficace mais un moment donné la lame au
voisin développe la résistance puis
l'herbicide glyphosate il devient
inefficace
ce chandail était vraiment problématique
c'est justement en utilisant ce produit
que sébastien bigras s'est rendu compte
que quelque chose n'allait pas on
s'était créé mon premier arrosage de
glyphosate alors on a vu qu'il y avait
un herbe qui paient pas morte après
après l'arrosage la marron tubercules et
qu'ils trouvent et finalement
résistantes à trois groupes d'herbicides
ce qui réduit grandement les options
pour s'en débarrasser l'an dernier cas
qu'on a vu le problème c'était un tapis
infesté d'amarante tubercules et on a
quand même empoché j'ai perdu mes deux
champs qui était le plus affecté fait
que je faisais que j'ai eu à rouen
demain cette année-là à l'été 2000 21 il
a utilisé un cocktail d'herbicides plus
chère et plus toxiques auquel l'amarante
n'y pas encore résistante on a dû faire
trois arrosage puis mes employés ont
aussi pensé dans les champs les plus
problématiques pour enlever les échappés
qui sont pas tombés avec les arrosages à
la main à la main
malgré tout il reste quelques plans ici
et là la vigilance sera donc toujours de
mise
sébastien bigras n'a aucune idée de la
façon dont cette plante est arrivé sur
sa ferme mais c'est souvent via la
machinerie que l'amarante se propage une
graine minuscule pu facilement se
dissimuler dans ces énormes mastodontes
et voyager sur de grandes distances s'il
ya des échanges de machinerie du battage
à forfait cette graine l'or va être
transportée via la batteuse
principalement chez d'autres producteurs
et puis le problème il y en avoir
partout au québec l'amarante tubercules
et aurait justement fait son entrée via
une moissonneuse batteuse usagés
importés des états unis même si la
réglementation stipule que tout
machinerie doit être nettoyée avant de
traverser les frontières les inspections
sont sporadiques et aucune amende n'est
prévu pourtant les conséquences pour
l'agriculture canadienne sont énormes
[Musique]
l'amarante tubercules et représentent
une telle menace que le gouvernement du
québec a décidé de débloquer des fonds
un montant de près de 7500 $ par ferme
est disponible pour défrayer notamment
les coûts liés à l'arrachage mais les
plantes réserve encore des surprises aux
agriculteurs